and you got to pick up and look to try  to camp one maybe even foul the clock is  not your friend of you the Warriors  especially when the bronze struggled to  make free throws this year but clearly  backing off  James again letting the clock run down  now makes his fool's game step back  three pointer LeBron James from downtown  oh that seals the deal  [Applause]  warriors call timeout James with his  third three-pointer and that makes it an  eight-point lead hills the crowd to  settle down gets to his spot elevates  over the contested hand knocks down the  dagger  that's getting it done mama bagels and  men normal did a good job contesting  James now 22 points 11 assists 8  rebounds and a Lakers